on the mound for the rockies with a
record of two in one and a 3.60 era
left-hander kyle freeland two-way and
mike trout the next batter a couple of
hits last night
one of the mvp front-runners in the
american league having another mike
trout season strike three called on the
next pitch of fastball
and that takes care of mike trout and
the angels here in the first
on the mound for the halos no record yet
but a 3.38 era right-hander jaime berea
nolan aronado gets the chance here in
the first
here's the pitch and that is a swing and
a miss and down on strikes on a high
slider is aronado and that'll win the
inning so bria gets his first strikeout
tonight we're scoreless after one second
is coming up rendon coming into the game
little three-game hitting streak he's
hitting 296. he was one for four in last
night's ball game 2-2 pitch
hits sharply to third it bounces off
nolan to trevor story who throws him out
josh fuentes
who had a two for four night last night
will be the next batter
this would lift it out toward the right
field toward foul territory walsh with
the over-the-shoulder catch
he's a troll defender as well jerry
walsh at first base
eric walsh's the batter he's having a
nice month of september hitting 370 for
the month
walsh last year
played in 34 games for the angels
pitched in five the pitch swing and a
miss and the back goes flying into the
rockies dugout or off the netting above
it and kyle freeland does the job
getting the big strikeout with simmons
at second base that closes out the top
of the third
so here's charlie blackmon with an
opportunity
and this will work go back in tag
trout makes the catch here comes walters
and he'll score the first run
another sac fly for charlie blackman
his 36th rbi nothing colorado two out
story's still at second and here's nolan
aronado
and at the plate now bouncing the ball
it hit off of the glove of berea and
[ __ ] knock the glove right out of its
hand and he picks the ball up with his
throwing hand and throws to first base
and gets aronado to in the inning angels
have runners everywhere they're loaded
for stassi with one out
and he'll drive one out toward left
field this one's hit well tapia moving
over makes the catch
throttle tag come in to score more tied
up at one as max stassi picks up his
13th rbi and now we'll see what joe
adele can do with two outs and runners
at first and second now let's see if
kyle can keep this damage to
one run the pitch is swung on and hit
high in the air center field ranging
back dull but he'll have room in front
of the track and he makes the catch for
out number three on one pitch adele
skies it to david dahl
iraqis have a one out base runner for
david dowell
pulls this on the right side fletcher
with a diving stop gets up throws the
walsh and they got him two down point
does it make a second look at that
difference he makes in the field for
fletch
one one game two outs ryan mcmahon at
the plate
three balls and two strikes the pitch
from berea swing and a base hit to left
field here comes fuentes around third
upton up with the ball he'll not offer a
throw to the plate big rbi single for
ryan mcmahon and the rockies take a two
to one lead
two out rbi's could be crushing to an
opponent see if murphy can come through
here
maria trying to keep it a one-run
deficit
fletcher is out in shallow right with
the shift on
murphy hits this one to the right side
simmons to his left has it and berea
does just
that angels have a base runner and
albert will be the next batter and
here's the next delivery and there's a
shot to temp on the left side that's
going to bang off the wall the ball gets
away from tapia now he finally retrieves
it and rindon is going to be waived home
and he will come in to score albert has
an rbi double and he is tied up the ball
game at two
runners at first and second
and we'll see what joe adele can do he's
had an over two night 3-2 pitch swag and
a miss he got him with a slider you just
have another opportunity here to put
some
more runs on the board this game's tied
at two anthony rindone at the plate
so random to step in in a 2-2 game and
he bounces it to the left side story in
the hole throws off balance in time and
a good job by almonte to bear down and
get anthony rendon and keep the angels
off the board that'll bring up charlie
blackmon
man in scoring position now fletcher's
out on shallow right sim is on the
second base side
blackman pulls this one over to second
base fletcher has it
we're off to the eighth inning knotted
up and two
daniel murphy tonight the dho for three
coldwad
slices this one out to left field up to
moving over and he'll dive and make the
catch nice play
on a ball that was sliding away from
justin upton
and fortunately it goes in the glove
that's an outstanding play so two all
with two outs and it's up to rendell
0-1 pitch
popped up
on the infield foul ground
fuentes calls off butera and makes the
catch big time pitch from daniel bard he
strands two
two down and rendone still at third in a
2-2 game in the 10th
and here's stasi long look in and the
one-two pitch swing and a miss
kinley fans stassy and leaves rendon
stranded at third
nolan with a chance to win it in the
10th here's the 2-2 delivery and this is
grounded right to short fielded by
simmons the throw to first base in
plenty of time and that is how the
inning will end
so here's jared walsh stepping up
walsh has had a lot of big hits for the
angels lately
next one on walsh he swings at this one
and lifts a high fly ball that's
carrying deep out into right center
field it's out of here
how about that
jared walsh is on some kind of a roll
right now
he just hits a three run homer he is
homered in the last four games he's
played in and the angels have a 5-2 lead
so here is david dahl at the plate
goal pops it up on the third base side
rindone moving over near the dugout
light that baby up as the angels pick up
the victory in extra innings tonight